I wanted to add that we do have to be
very careful when you talk about the
importance of
um speaking from a place of logic and
not immediately advocating for emotional
Detachment because
your your feelings are valid you just
don't have to always uh walk in them and
express them I think we have to be able
to separate the two and whilst we're
speaking about communication Styles I do
feel like a lot of men do practice
emotional
um Detachment in in in situations with
women with the whole like keep them mean
keep them Keen kind of like attitude and
it might not be intentional but they
know that it's equally as effective as
for example a woman crying if I know
that emotionally Detachment situation
she's probably going to that later on to
me a bit more so I just don't think your
feelings are always valid like I think
sometimes your feelings are stupid no no
they can be strong right over the
dumbest like the like or you know how it
is like when before your period yeah and
you'll you'll look back like a couple
days later and you're like what was I
doing okay but in the in the future
perhaps then but in that present moment
you cried for a reason it was a real
feeling I'm not saying that they're
important I'm just saying that there was
a real thing that and you're allowed to
feel things have you have you ever have
you ever like Pearl was saying have you
ever cried out of something that you
looked back on and said what that why
why was I even crying absolutely right
okay so men generally yeah okay right if
a man cries it's because of something
men don't cry over oh my God I went to
the restaurant today or went to the
coffee shop saying I never had my
favorite croissant and I was on my
period and so I was like oh my God
guys don't do that right but what I'm
trying to say dogs don't do that
yesterday
you were right I'm a boy because I don't
behave like that my period is three days
clean quick don't get emotional don't
get paid I've been a cry for no reason I
don't like to cry I like to talk
straight and logic facts anyway the
point I'm making is that if you know as
a woman you've looked back on
times that you've cried and been
emotional right and known that maybe I
was overreacting a little bit maybe I
was hormonal maybe I was on my period
right and we know as men that we
generally don't do that when when
as men
when it comes to communication when do
we take you seriously
now honest question like when if if we
know that women can cry over that kind
of stuff okay if a woman comes to us
crying when when do we take you
seriously two days after the emotional
breakdown
kind of look to men to like deciphers
yeah like how curious is this yeah
because I feel like men should go off of
there because you guys are more
naturally logical than us like I feel
like you should not ask a woman when to
take use off seriously because a girl
when she's very serious the reason why I
asked that is because women always say
oh I know my period but
if we say
uh shut up
if we say oh just chill out man it's not
that you're not taking me seriously so
all right so if I'm not taking seriously
now when you're on your period when do I
take you seriously when you're off your
period remember to me
three days before your period
you sound so logical like maybe I just
need a hug well you don't have to like
rationalize this whole situations
don't actually want guys to fix the
problem no I guess when you behave me
and I don't know
figure it out I just want us to make you
feel better in the moment
you can't ask me what do I want because
I don't know it's hard to do that when
you're in the wrong though you know what
I mean I want to ask girls how many guy
friends do you have like brethrens how
many do you have do you have a lot
because I'm not gonna lie if you have a
lot of guys around you that your
graduates they'll tell you shut up no
not really no no they're kind of fun
a lot of princess treatment for my
friends my brothers
your guy friends are trying to sleep
with you
okay so so do you do you have a guy
friend who wouldn't
yes can you call him girl oh my God
do you know do you know how you can get
candles okay no no I'm saying like like
you could you use my phone no he
wouldn't yeah but I know I need the
numbers
so ladies are you literally you really
believe that your guy friends quote
unquote guy friends that if you called
them up at like 12 midnight
and said oh you know what I've always
kind of thought about
something could have happened between us
come round right now
hell no yeah any woman who genuinely
feels like girls and guys can be friends
is naive like you've given the
opportunity
circumstances under someone's
something since you understand now
they were my close guy friends are queer
I'll be like this no they're gay and
that's why it works because they're not
looking for me they're like they're not
looking for me outside of that I've had
to change oh no we
it's an equivocation to think that men
and women cannot have platonic
friendships
they can't only be only when women
create those boundaries
if you like girls can be quote unquote
or women can be friends with men but men
can't immediately be friends because
given the opportunity he would bang so
you are creating the parameter listen
like whatever the case I just know that
still means he wants to [ __ ] you right
exactly
no not really that's not even the case I
my friendships with my friends the way
they've started were very natural it
wasn't anything about sexual we always
started with a very deep conversation
about real stuff so they understood the
kind of woman that I am and they put the
sexuality aside why because they
respected the way they approach them and
they respect everything
but when you look at the room though
gain 150 pounds I wonder if they're
still your friend oh yeah of course they
will okay listen I've gone up and down
with these friends and they're always
there
are you telling me that you've been
alone with these guys
at
an interesting hour of the Night Under
the Influence I'm gonna Implement and
and no one's done anything definitely oh
my God even now like sometimes even
yesterday one of my brothers was around
I was at home I finished my Bros yeah
and I said I even have yo bro
we hang out we talk about uh business
plans to talk about what we are on
projects we plan
um I cook for them because I like to
cook for people we hang out with
children bed with them yes and and
obviously I don't have to because they
will live there I've shared bed with my
friends you know what it is and they
don't even touch me trust me
homosexual no they said you know what it
is
exactly they're just waiting on standby
in it like no if you stuck it on them
then they would go with the phone 100
million percent they will go with the
flow if you stuck it on them because
you're not sticking it on them they're
just like oh just I'll just stay in my
legs I stay in my Lane I'm not gonna
overstep I heard I heard you can tell me
if this is true I heard that guys are
friends with girls because they know at
some point the girls will [ __ ] their
friends if they wait around long enough
yeah the whole friend zone
the men in friend zones are very
successful like you just I've always
said it's like I'm curious all right
raise your hand like the girls here
raise your hand if you've had a guy make
it out of the friend zone
no one see that make it out yeah make it
out I have I have
really yeah I have but I'm hoping that
my best but then why was he in there oh
my God
for a man I need to understand why was
he in the friend zone and what was it
what was it that made him out that made
him be able to get out of the friend
zone
um he was in the friend zone because
we
he was just a bit too
much of a little bit too
like I just felt like he wouldn't like
commit if I ever went there because he
was just yeah but then we were friends
for like a couple years and so and so we
became less of a hoe
um yeah he kind of settled down like he
wasn't as wild as he like used to be
okay okay and then
huh and then then and then they weren't
friends anymore what happened what do
you do this makes you realize women are
always in control of sex
women are always in control of sex when
it comes to like that like men are never
in control of sexual situations if a
woman can keep you on standby for two
years I'm ready now it's like
friends
my guy friends from high school
you really want to prove this the ones
now you're about to hit 30. you might
start looking in the floor Maybe
for me I did say this I said listen
these people be trying to talk and say
that I can't find a man and I'm going to
be stuck and hit a wall worst case I
will have a best friend I'll give me a
baby oh my goodness
so if you can take your guy out the
friend zone
for the right one now no no no no but
it's because rewind back to your point
you're trying to escape
your contradictions
about turkey baster so basically what I
want now is I'm tired of having to think
about committing to somebody for the
rest of my life that I'm not quite sure
about and I don't know so I'll just say
I'll pick the with somebody that is
genetically nice and fit you'll become
my best friend we'll hang out if you're
really cool enough we'll have a baby we
take care of the baby but there's not
much more to it that's it
no that's because I'm changing my mind
you sound like a man you don't think
that's selfish to be to be voluntarily
be bring up a kid and where their
parents aren't together to do that like
on purpose because love it's like love
doesn't mean that you have to kiss each
other and be like oh my God you're my
husband and my wife love comes in so
many different shapes and forming I
think that what's healthy is for a child
to have love and to be able to
understand that they have two parents
that love them they care for them
what would kind of say one thing what
would be better what would be better
um a kid that has a parent in two
different homes or a kid that is a
parent in both homes well if the parent
both homes and getting all along you'd
rather have them in different homes
I just want your healthy parents I'm
saying this is before there's not even
fighting yet I'm saying like you're
picking this so before the kids even
like you're not even giving the the real
thing a shot so okay I'll say it but
because I I talk about myself right
everything that says based on my own
experience right you talk about yourself
obviously uh there's only one denial of
us so all of a sudden I need to let you
guys know you don't I'm enough but I
would definitely say for me I feel like
I'm healthier having a a good balance of
my own space and Independence and having
somebody that I can also spend some time
with in company but realistically at
this point looking at how things are
going having these conversations I
realized that you know
um unconditional forever loving marriage
seems a bit bogus
can I just say something
um I need to start I'm gonna get a sign
here I can press the button I want a
[ __ ]
signals because you're talking pure
[ __ ] you just said I said that no no
this is my point of view from what you
said right men can't men and women can
be friends right you've got male friends
they're not going to come at the friend
zone they're going to stay in the friend
zone because that's the way you are but
if by chance now that you decide that
you're getting old and that you want a
child you're gonna hand pick the best
meal out of all of your friends to have
a child with than to separate that's
selfish [ __ ] because now you're
never gonna turn around and say that
that is selfish [ __ ] because you're
not even thinking about the child you're
just being selfish you are going you
might as well go to one of them sperm
banks and get a child from a sperm bank
or get IVF because you're going out
there and you're deliberately choosing
to put a child I'm not a step person at
a disadvantage as a single person on
purpose am I that
isn't it
she didn't say anything about single
parents
let me finish she just said right you
can rewind it later on she did say that
she will go out there she will get one
of her friends she will have a child
because she don't believe in all this
happy relationship love forever after
that she will have a child with one of
the men that she is hand-picked one of
her friends and then she will separate
a genetically fit man but you're going
to be an old dog boy then and nobody's
gonna really do because things are going
I've got five years and then a minute
you're 30. you've got you're saying
you've got five years but how do your
body got five years because you're not a
biologist and you can't tell I know she
just said that she was going to go out
there and she that is why Pearl asks you
doesn't that selfish or why are you
going out there and deliberately
deciding to have a child as a single
parent what would you like that I'd love
you shut your legs and don't have no
children if you can't be in a healthy
relationship will a man and woman
together getting on well to raise a
child together and you're deliberately
going out there and choosing to have a
child as a single parents
what did you say because what I said is
I would rather have a child with two
parents in separate homes than to have
them under one home in a toxic situation
you said but I'm saying you didn't even
try to have the relationship with the a
friend because I don't know okay okay
but that's that's the whole that's
Handy's whole point yeah is you're
picking listen listen okay you're
picking to be a single parent without
even trying no it's one thing it's one
thing okay to be in love and then you
guys can't work it out and then later I
mean I still think you should work it
out that that's a whole nother
conversation but that's that's a
separate situation then going in and
saying you know what I don't think I can
get along with a man so but because I
want a kid I'm gonna raise him in a
situation where they're they're in two
separate houses which we know which we
know isn't good for the kids okay
because otherwise it's going to be toxic
like why why is it it's going to be a
toxic situation
why can't it just be that you try to get
along with the guy friend it's the same
thing that Nick Cannon is doing in it
he's having babies
let me finish let me finish let me land
Let Me Lie what I'm saying is at the end
of the day Nick Cannon understood that
the most important thing is not the fact
that the parents need to be together is
how much you can provide for the child
and that's why I said I want somebody to
get on with so that actually when I do
have a kid it's co-parenting in the
healthiest of ways you want to be a
sister wife
is that what you call them yeah like if
you if there's a man who's a who's a
high value Alpha man and he breeds I
don't know six seven women you want to
be one of you want to be no a man who's
a concubine that's a woman who's a
concubine to a very high level I'm
explaining okay
because he's a parent that is not
present in everything and he's probably
not and he's probably not a good father
because how are you possible how are you
possibly a good present father for all
of those six children when you're not
impressive okay no that's hone it into
my example I'm not saying that I'm going
to be with a man that has a million
children I can have all of his kids it's
okay and what we do is we together as
people we know now know that we've come
together to bring life and to make sure
that that life grows healthily it's not
about me and you because normally the
issues that people have is that they
make about their relationship and then
who suffers is the kid
let me just get this straight okay I
just wanna I just want to clarify you
think the best situation for a kid is to
find a friend and then raise that kid in
two separate homes rather rather than
maybe find a friend and think hmm maybe
I can make this guy my husband and learn
to get along with a man
and and raise the kid under a house with
two parents and not make it toxic and
make make it your mission to have a
happy healthy home so I I listen I've
got to this point of understanding what
I actually need in my life and I
understand that I need space because I
don't have the mental capacity to have
to trust somebody who I don't know the
ins and outs people you don't have the
mental capacity
you go into things with fear yeah
there's no future yeah so so it's like
if you constantly maybe come change my
mind your future husband you know but
like if you're constantly thinking
what's the worst thing that can happen
it's going to be toxic like a good man
who would treat you right is going to be
scared off because he's getting this
girl that's saying well I don't know
every part of you how can I trust you
and and so the guy that actually would
treat you right and be a good dad is
going to be scared off by that okay and
another thing as well
this is one of the reasons why I've
always said to men right don't listen to
what women say watch what they do
there's a difference okay it's because
this woman then Alva will come on the
show and say yeah but you know it's a
friend's own man's not coming out he's
not coming out the friend zone
what's she gonna do 10 years later and
another thing what women do can I just
not listening
I want to add something quickly um I
feel like we go we are going into these
situations with these high expectations
of I need to know somebody 100 you're
never going to know somebody's ins and
out 100 we don't even know ourselves 100
like the process of like the
individuation process We Are Forever
Learning people are forever changing so
that fear of like I can't go into the
situation and not trust somebody just
get rid of that
I know you're trying to safeguard
yourself and I understand when you first
said about the fact that you know
traditional companionship is a bit dated
in this modern day but it's possible so
like just don't don't like make it like
I understand that but let me tell you
something yeah the more I open my eyes
up to the world around me is the more
that I understand everybody is quite
messed up in their own way yeah but you
always still feel pain that's all right
but I would rather feel pain where I can
actually deal with it better than to
have to feel pain from someone else
Whose actions
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible